how much does trauma
of that kind and and later in life
affect your ability to love another
human being
say inside a relationship connect with
another human being
it can impact it a lot and again I want
to say can people overcome and be as
loving to to a partner or a child or
anyone else yes but we're talking across
Society right how are we setting the
odds right we're setting the odds
towards a higher sense of vigilance a
decreased sense of self-confidence an
increased sense of vulnerability right a
decreased Comfort interacting with
others right what we're doing is we're
pushing towards isolation and misery and
depression and resentment I mean those
factors push towards that you know we
know that the research is so strong that
at you know adverse childhood
experiences and these things that happen
the more the worse the more prolonged
the more that person is up against as
they try and navigate life
and uh I suppose one of the elements of
intimacy like we were talking about is
is vulnerability
and maybe there's a
is there a fear of being vulnerable
of being hurt again
choose that ultimately the barrier to
intimacy yeah if you taught a lesson
that says the world is not safe
and you're not good enough for someone
to keep safe and you're not strong
enough to keep yourself safe that's a
final common pathway of of the vast
majority of child abuse right is telling
those lessons to people then how how can
that not
change the lay of the land against
against openness against the ability to
to rationally consider trust and
mutuality and to protect oneself but
also take chances and you know do the
things that we have to do to to create
the greatest happiness in our lives we
set the odds so much against us as
another pathway which I think is uh is
really
interesting because of uh I've seen it
in people is is this kind of ability to
detach yourself
from feeling any emotions
to like protect yourself
it's almost like you're not quite there
it is a word physical isolation of
affect it's a defense mechanism yeah
isolation of affect yeah is that a
common weight another
common way to deal with trauma
well
isolation of affect can cut both ways so
so if there's been a major trauma let's
say someone has seen something terrible
and they're isolated from their affect
and at one time it was thought well
maybe that's good right they're not
hysterical they're not distraught but we
see that is not good right because what
needs to be be held processed you know
we need to get our arms around in some
way shape or form has just been
separated off right so we know that is
not good right but isolation of affect
can also serve us very well when I think
back to being an intern you know a
medical intern in the hospital and you
know you might have to go and
pronounce someone Dead with you know
with hysterical family members and then
you know 10 minutes later five minutes
later might be two minutes later really
you know you have to go to another room
and you've got to maybe do some
procedure that involves you know having
your focus on on a certain thing and
making sure your hand movements are the
right way or talking to a person in a
way that is uh that's very different
than where you just came from that's
very hopeful and so then you have to
isolate the affect of what's going on
around you and it happens not just in
it's just one example but we have to do
it in life so that we can put affect
aside to process later or not feel the
full weight of affect where we know the
meaning like I know the meaning of the
tragedy of the person I just pronounced
dead but I want to separate that for
myself because I'm also aware that it's
not my tragedy so that I can then okay
put that affect aside and go do the next
thing that I have to do so that I think
can cut both ways
right but then you have to like reattach
it
understand that it's good to be close
with emotion even painful emotion
right right like because that's the
Human Experience right it's it's like I
feel like if you if you build up a skill
that you can detach yourself from
emotion
I think that could become its own kind
of yeah it could become too easy to do
it yeah right and to reinforce that's
when people are suffering too much
over too long a period of time then you
know we're creatures of habit right and
even though our brains are you talking
about our brains are sitting on the
shoulders of the giant of the maybe a
thousand levels of emergence that come
underneath of them our brains are also
also working very simple habit based
ways like if you and I chose a word
right now and said it 500 times we would
know it's just a silly experiment but
we'd both be saying it tonight right
because our brains are also creatures of
habit so if you over and over and over
have to isolate yourself from affect and
you develop those mechanisms well you
develop those mechanisms and they don't
go away any easier than if we said the
word 500 times and decided to forget we
won't forget no matter what we decided